welcome to this video playing sharp
O'Toole from Mexico well I'll take
Mexico yes okay a French defense and
somehow he played is six instantly and
now g5 takes takes a bit of time
normally I play 92 here let's play 93
for change so I'm not really an expert
if all player so it's all a bit shaky my
knowledge I could take all let him take
i can i can set this Q trap knight takes
Bishop takes Knight f6 97 but okay he
didn't fall for that so let's just just
develop aha my haircut I could take with
the Queen to the Sun an idea it's
getting the Queen over to age form now
maybe very crude but quite often and
Blitzer those kind of texts I'm are
effective yeah in fact here I can take
h7 winning a pawn yeah okay come on
let's check let's win this pawn e7 this
is unprotected
okay so I'm not sure what Knight f6 is
doing could play Bishop g5 for example I
could also take c7 yeah why not yet
another pawn okay how to play that now
his queen he probably wants to play the
bishop to see 6am let's let's grab this
temple he will probably go to age 5 and
then my idea was play 95 but took aim I
need to be cautious that I'm not falling
behind the development too much maybe I
should just ok ok I don't mind to have
this useful move in and now is entering
on c2 so probably will see am coming ok
ok let's protect see form look see a
time going back to our form yeah f4
probably I could also go to g3 I but
then maybe 94 don't know f4 seems like a
good return it square a black has some
yeah not really enough compensation but
a bit of can at least em BM gap and can
attack attack am a booty on the light
squares 95 or something and then not at
the moment the bishop is hanging but in
general it's am it's not sufficient them
and I'm not too far behind on the clock
I try to play Queen D to get this get
the Queen out I don't want you to take
him okay so 22 or is this it's not
really helping much the smooth Jam 23 I
have Queen d2 ok I take this under
control efore and now let's see maybe
just just move the bishop ashok d to
Yakima I'd like to get rid of the Queen
if you retreat somewhere to f5 or I
cannot even go to a 55 a player g4 and
the printed strapped I mean at least in
he needs to ok so just before or take it
taking the trolley easy
yes I'd like to control the ATM to
cannot play d 8
my display I'm not to be formed thee
success hanging but i don't i don't
really want to take it looks like
unnecessary tactics night before it's
not really helping it's got the a pawn
then
yeah maybe I should play night F form
can I get rid of this night need to
protect you for to do that nope this
helps he's saying whoops resigns yep
it's a big oops but ok it's two pawns
and I probably if he if he moves the
rock I'll probably win it in the long
run say rookie and probably just drop
the bishop e mc2 yeah it's probably when
the the the pawns restrict lucky too
much am I also can use the kingside to
to make this to two pawns like the f
porn to advance the f porn and try to
use them the jeep on its two much two
pawns and they it's them it's also big
difference that looks on the board just
with the bishops there are always some
drawing chances opposite kind of bishops
yeah in fact it all came down to who
down down to giving away those two pawns
and it didn't really got enough
compensation alright thanks for watching